prime minister modi
excellencies ambassadors
distinguished guests
every five years
when indians are casting their vote
in parliamentary elections
the world watches with admiration
as the world's largest democracy
charts its future path
because the outcome of decisions made by
1.3 billion people
resonates around the globe
this is especially true for europe
as vibrant democracies
india and the european union share
fundamental values
and common interests
together we believe in each country's
right
to determine its own destiny
together
we believe in the rule of law
and fundamental rights
and together we believe that it is
democracy
that best delivers for citizens
so despite our geographic distance
and despite the different languages we
speak
when we look at each other
we do not meet as strangers
but as close friends
democracy was born
more than two thousand years ago
in europe
but today
its largest home
is india
for the european union strengthening
and energizing
its partnership with india is a priority
in this upcoming decade
both our economies thrive in a world of
common rules
and fair competition
and we share the same interests
in safe trading routes
in seamless supply chains
and in a free
and open
in the pacific
both our regions are driving forces in
the digital revolution
and this makes us natural partners in
setting global standards
to make sure that the rules of the
analog world
also count in the digital domain
and of course both
india and the european union are key in
the transition to more sustainable and
green future for our planet
so we must pool our strength in the
fight against climate change it's so
urgent
and this is our common responsibility
not only towards the global community
but mostly towards the next generation
however
our values are not shared by everyone
we all see the rising challenges to our
open and free societies
this is true for the technological
and the economic domain
but it is also true for security
the reality is
that the core principles
that underpin peace and security across
the world
are at stake
in asia as well as in europe
the images coming from russia's attack
on ukraine
have shocked and are shocking the whole
world
two weeks ago
i visited butcher
the suburb
of keefe
which was devastated by russian troops
as they withdrew from the north of
ukraine
i saw with my own eyes
the bodies lined up on the ground
i saw the mass graves
i listened to survivors of atrocious
crimes
the kremlin soldiers committed
i saw the scars of bomb schools and
resident houses
and hospitals
these are severe violations of
international law
targeting and killing innocent civilians
redrawing borders by force
subjugating the will of a free people
this goes against core principles
enshrined in the u.n charter
in europe
we see russia's aggression as a direct
threat to our security
we will make sure that the unprovoked
and unjustified aggression against
ukraine
will be a strategic failure
this is why we're doing all we can to
help ukraine fight for its freedom
this is why we immediately imposed
massive sharp
and effective sanctions
sanctions are never a stand-alone
solution
they are embedded in a broader strategy
that has diplomatic and security
elements
and this is why we have designed the
sanctions in a way
to sustain them over a longer period of
time
because this gives us leverage to
achieve a diplomatic solution that will
bring lasting peace
and we urge all members of the
international community to support our
efforts
for lasting peace
and if we consider what it means for
europe and asia
that russia and china have forged a
seemingly
unrestrained pact
they have declared that the friendship
between them has no limits
that there are no forbidden areas of
cooperation
this was in february this year
and then
the invasion of ukraine followed
what can we expect from the new
international relations
that both have called for
ladies and gentlemen
this is
a defining moment
our decisions in these days will shape
decades to come
our response to russia's aggression
today
will decide the future of both the
international system
and the global economy
will heinous devastation win
or humanity prevail
will the right of might
dominate or the rule of law
will there be constant conflict and
struggle
or a future of common prosperity
and lasting peace
what happens in ukraine will have an
impact on the indo-pacific region it
already has
countries battered by two years of covet
pandemic must deal now with rising
prices for grain
energy and fertilizers as a direct
result
of putin's war of choice
thus
the outcome of the war
will not only determine the future of
europe
but also deeply affect
the indo-pacific region and the rest of
the world
for the indo-pacific region it is as
important as for europe
that borders are respected
and that spheres of influence are
rejected
we want a positive vision
for a peaceful and prosperous
indo-pacific region
the region is home to half of the
world's population
and 60 percent of the global gdp
our vision is
that the indo-pacific region
remains free
and open
and becomes more interconnected
prosperous
secure
and resilient
will with an open and rules-based
security architecture that serves all
interests
to this end
we will deepen our engagement with our
partners in the region including asean
on china
we will continue to encourage beijing
to play its part
in a peaceful and thriving indo-pacific
region
the relationship between the european
union
and china
is simultaneously
strategically important
and challenging
all at once
china is a negotiating partner
an economic competitor
and a systemic rival
we will continue our multifaceted
engagement
we will continue to cooperate on
tackling common challenges
and we will protect our essential
interests and promote our values
and on this foundation of engagement in
the indo-pacific region we seek to build
a new
common agenda
for the 21st century
one major item on this agenda is the
need around the world for massive
investment
to overcome the fallout
of the coveted pandemic and to modernize
the economies
and as a consequence some countries have
been forced to take unsustainable offers
they face a situation
where they do not fully control
their own infrastructure be it seaports
or airports
be it bridges
or railways
but investments in our future should
never come at the expense
of a country's independence
throughout the 2020s
developing asian countries will need to
invest more than five percent
of the gross domestic product
to meet the infrastructure needs of
their own fast growing economies
this means globally over 1.7
trillion dollars per year
the needs are massive
but so are the opportunities
this is why we have introduced global
gateway
global gateway
is europe's vision for investment in
clean
and sustainable global infrastructure
global gateway will enable up to 300
billion euros
to support major infrastructure
priorities around the world
from clean energy
to digitalization you name it
our offer will be transparent
and values driven
with europe
what you see is what you get
and let me focus on specifically two
points
first on climate action
and here let me take energy
energy demand for example in india
has doubled since 2000
and this is good news
because it means better living condition
for millions of people
over the next 20 years
india will need an additional
energy capacity
that is equal to the entire european
energy consumption
additional
so the question is
will this energy be clean
or will it poison our air that we
breathe
will the energy be renewable and
homegrown
or will it increase our dependency and
allow for blackmail in the future
i was very glad prime minister to hear
that you declared that india will be
energy independent
before it celebrates
its 100th birthday
of the country's independence in 2047.
[Applause]
so the choices made today are crucial
not just for this great nation
but for the whole world
global gateway could bring for example
to india and bangladesh
more hydropower produced in nepal and
bhutan
it could build clean hydrogen
infrastructure to power up
your heavy industries
just yesterday i visited the
headquarters of the international solar
alliance
this is a great partnership launched by
prime minister modi and now bringing
together 86 countries
so it's innovation
at the service of people because the
international service alliance will
benefit most
the least developed countries and the
small island developing states
and given the geopolitical and climate
challenges we face the business case
today for solar is stronger than ever
so we should massively scale it up also
through global gateway for the benefit
of our common prosperity and the planet
we all share
we also can help the climate
when saving energy
i know this sounds obvious
but in a country
the size of india the sum of many small
individual decisions
can have a tremendous overall impact in
the end
just think of this example
as price has dropped dramatically
in recent years millions of indians
switched from using
traditional old light bulbs
to modern led lighting technology
this resulted in annual energy savings
of 30 terawatt hours
this is roughly enough to power 28
million average indian households for a
year just by saving
or for the whole of denmark
just through saving energy
so there's really big time potential in
energy
efficiency and energy savings
we also need to strengthen our
cooperation in the digital field
this is my second point
because cutting ed technology
is at the heart
of our future cooperation
and asia is a powerhouse when it comes
to new technologies from artificial
intelligence to quantum computing
our cooperation is about more
than investment and infrastructure
it is about talent and technology
based on fundamental values
on standards for example
today
india and the european union both
recognize that we are better off
when we develop global standards for new
technologies such as 5g instead of
seeking separate national solutions
and we share many of the same values
when it comes to the digital world
we share the idea
that privacy should be guaranteed online
as well as offline
and that technology technology should
enhance
individual freedom
not the state's ability to control us
think about data protection
european companies outsource many of
their i t processes to indian companies
europe generates almost one third of the
revenues for the indian business process
outsourcing sector
and with equivalent rules
we could unlock even greater data flows
between our regions with immense
benefits
for the companies in our respective
regions
as i said earlier
for the european union the partnership
with this region
is one of our most important
relationships for the coming decade
and strengthening this partnership
is a priority for the european union
our strategic cooperation should take
place at the nexus of trade
trusted technology and security
notably in the in respect of challenges
posed by rival
governance models
and therefore i am very pleased that
today prime minister modi and i
have agreed to establish an eu india
trade and technology council to tackle
key trade economic and technological
challenges
[Applause]
and as like-minded partners the european
union at india will be working on
several tracks
we have launch negotiations
on a free trade agreement
as well as uh on investment protection
and geographical indications for europe
this is a strategic investment in our
partnership with india
the european union is india's third most
important trade partner
but we can do so much more
our trade is far below our potential
both for indian and european goods and
services
so this deal
will bring new technologies new
investment and unprecedented integration
into shared value chains
we are the two largest democracies in
the world
and together we have a lot to give
to the benefit for the benefit of the
people
ladies and gentlemen
we are living indeed
in a terra nova
as the title of this year's resina
dialogue suggests
we all have to choose
whether we want a terra nova
to be wild
dangerous
and an unlivable place
or a better home for all humankind
i am convinced
that democracies will have a crucial
role to play in defining the world of
tomorrow
i want europe
to be a partner for asian shaping this
new world
a world of independent
yet interconnected countries
working together for more prosperous
and peaceful world
working together
for the benefit of humankind
thank you very much for your attention
[Applause]
bye